most people seem to have some idea about
how a more carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere causes global warming
something about heat being trapped but
they don't have the whole story now I'm
going to try and tell you that full
story but I need to tell you two little
bits of physics first firstly if we have
an object at a temperature T then the
amount of energy flowing into and out of
that object determines whether that
temperature changes so if more energy is
flowing in than out then that
temperature increases
whereas if more energy is flowing out
than in then that temperature must
decrease and secondly any object at
temperature T radiates energy out at a
rate proportional to the fourth power of
its temperature what that means then is
that a really hot object emits an awful
lot more energy than a cooler object so
the earth as an object gets all of its
energy from the Sun which is a very hot
object emits an awful lot of energy Sun
which is light which we see some of
which is thermal radiation which we feel
is heat and the earth absorbs some of
this radiation and it heats up until the
amount of energy which it's radiating
out equals amount of energy which is
absorbing from the Sun but the earth as
an object doesn't radiate with the
temperature equal to the average surface
temperature of the earth this is because
while the atmosphere is transparent to
radiation with visible wavelengths light
it's not transparent of radiation with
thermal wavelengths or heat radiation so
thermal radiation given off by the
Earth's surface then gets absorbed by
the atmosphere just above the surface
which then reradiates some of that
energy which then gets absorbed by the
layer of atmosphere just above that and
so on and so forth but because the other
that mistake gets thinner the higher you
go eventually reach a point where energy
emitted by a layer in the atmosphere
doesn't get absorbed by the atmosphere
above it because that atmosphere is just
du Vin and so that energy then escapes
off to space that layers temperature
then is the temperature at which the
earth radiates energy out of space and
because the temperature gets lower the
higher you go in the atmosphere that
temperature is much lower than the
surface temperature of the earth so
where does co2 come into all of this
well by adding more co2 into the
atmosphere we're making even less
transparent thermal radiation and what
this means is you then have to go higher
in the atmosphere before that thermal
radiation can escape off into space and
because the temperature gets colder the
higher you go this means then that the
earth starts to radiate at a lower
temperature which means it starts to
radiate less energy and because the same
amount of energy is coming in from the
Sun but less is leaving the earth
the earth as an object has to warm up
and the more co2 we put into the
atmosphere the more warming we see and
the faster it gets thanks very much for
watching this video and I've included
some links in the description if you
would like to learn more about global
warming or climate change